so here's an interesting question what
if your only protein source
came from egg what would happen
would you build up all this cholesterol
in your arteries and die of a heart
attack maybe a stroke
well actually no you would not let me
explain why
in six
major clinical studies it was found that
eggs did not increase or was not
associated with heart disease in healthy
people they talk about all the benefits
of eggs and how it doesn't create a
problem other than increase your good
cholesterol
and have all these other nutrients but
the recommendation is really less than
two eggs a day which is interesting if
eggs are so good
why aren't they recommending that and
i'm going to get to that in a minute if
you look at any
in all negative studies relating to eggs
they're all questionnaire studies
they're observational studies and those
are not real credible studies at all so
if you have a political slant or maybe a
certain bias and you want a study to
look a certain way
just do an observational study because
you could make those look any which way
you want and you're basically just
giving people a bunch of questions and
forcing them to answer
a certain way
first of all how is someone going to
remember what they ate even
two days ago let alone
months or even years ago
so what would happen if you just relied
on eggs as your only source of protein
you'd actually do much better
health-wise and that's what i want to
get into in this video i think the big
problem that people have with eggs is
being brainwashed i mean educated in
that eggs are high in cholesterol when
in fact they are high in cholesterol
okay but they also contain lecithin okay
which is the antidote to cholesterol
they're loaded with choline which is in
it's actually one of the ingredients in
bile salts that helps break down
cholesterol and as well as b3 which is
probably the best antidote to
cholesterol problems so if you're
concerned at all about eggs increasing
your cholesterol and making things worse
you don't have to have that concern
anymore now what's so different about
eggs
versus other sources of protein
the egg is the highest quality
source of protein
other than breast milk okay it has
virtually every nutrient that you need
and it's uh its amino acid profile is
complete
the nutrients and amino acids are very
bioavailable the waste product from eggs
is so minimal because you're utilizing
all this great protein so eggs are
number one
meat is number two
dairy is three
and plant-based protein is low on the
list in fact the protein you get from
plant-based sources is actually pretty
poor and unfortunately as much as you
hear on the news about everything
shifting the plant base that
every man woman and child should be a
vegan
you have to realize that the studies are
observational and there's so much
political bias going on right now
regarding plant-based away from real
science and of course the attack against
red meat is big time
they put in the same category as
processed meat and even of the same
caliber as like sugar and refined sugars
so here you have this meat that we've
been eating for
you know thousands and thousands of
years it's just not just nutrient dense
but if you're consuming something that's
grass-fed grass
finished you're getting a very
high source of protein that can greatly
help you not just with your muscles but
repair the proteins overall in general
sometimes people think about proteins as
just muscle but you have
all the enzymes in your body the
different metabolic pathways are all
protein
a good portion of your skin is protein
good portion of your bone is protein
your immune system is protein so when
we're trying to replenish or repair
proteins we need sufficient proteins and
a bioavailable source that our body can
really use efficiently but eggs are at
the top of the list okay one egg will
give you seven grams of protein and
virtually every single nutrient it may
not give you all the vitamin c
but it will give you
the b vitamins
vitamin a
vitamin d
vitamin e
vitamin k1 and k2
omega 3 fatty acids so this is packed
full with nutrients okay so
other types of protein are just like
muscle protein but egg is a very unique
source of protein because it's not just
a muscle protein and there's a lot of
amazing things and additional
factors that can help your health
one being
something called sphingomyelin okay what
is that well that's a compound that can
help prevent plaquing in your
vascular system so if you're still hung
up on this idea that eggs might clog
your arteries actually it doesn't it
actually prevents the plaquing of your
arteries
choline
which is a really important nutrient
that can help prevent a fatty liver
in fact if you're deficient in choline
you will get a fatty liver but choline
is also necessary for a healthy brain
and choline is a really good antidote to
uh high cholesterol okay lutein and
zeaxanthin these are two compounds
that greatly support the macula of the
eye that's the back part of the eye and
the macula helps you with central vision
it also will help
to act as a like a filter for
for uv radiation as well as filtering
blue light
so there's a thing called age-related
macular degeneration
and these two compounds can help prevent
that condition
then we have something called
phospholipids what's that it's
combination between lipids and
phosphorus which is a great
anti-inflammatory it's very important in
building your cell membranes
and then we have the the protein and egg
so people have been confused about the
egg whites and the yolk okay they think
that all the protein is in the egg
whites but did you realize that if we
compare per 100 gram of the yolk versus
the white the yolk
has 16.4 grams of protein per 100 gram
and the white only has 10.8 grams
of protein
per 100 gram so
per weight
the yolk has more protein not to mention
it has so many other things that are
essential for repair and even preventing
something called sarcopenia which is a
age-related muscle loss condition
in fact i'll put one study below that
compares consuming whole eggs versus
just the egg whites
and
it demonstrated that if you have the
whole egg you have better results
with post exercise repair and muscle
building so
if you're trying to build muscle and
you're just doing the egg whites you
might want to do the whole egg the other
thing i'm going to mention as a side
note is what about just you know
drinking your eggs raw
well the problem with raw eggs and i'm
not against it in certain amounts but
raw eggs have a protease inhibitor okay
that means that
the enzyme to help break down protein is
inhibited so you may not get the full
benefit of that egg white not to mention
you may develop a biotin
deficiency if you have a large amount
and so this compound
is
kind of nullified when you heat the egg
when you cook the egg and the best form
of an egg i would recommend is something
like an over easy egg where the egg yolk
is runny okay but you're cooking the
white part but even if you scramble your
egg or your hard boiler egg you're still
gaining a lot of benefits so i don't
want to get too far in the woods with
the cooking methods of an egg but i will
say that
at this point realize that eggs in
general are super super healthy
especially if you want to get a high
quality source of amino acid there's
even some data on certain compounds and
eggs giving an anti-cancer effect
as well as an immuno modulation effect
which can help
regulate your immune system so the idea
of consuming eggs as your primary
protein source
it really the only drawback i see that
it has
is nothing related to health it has to
do with maybe boredom and making your
foods more interesting by adding
different protein sources but if you
were to just to consume eggs as your
primary protein source you would not
only increase your health but you would
probably increase your digestion as well
because eggs seem to be very easily
digested for most people unless you have
an allergy so realize that eggs only
have seven grams of protein right so
depending on your the size of your body
how much you weigh how much muscle you
have
your age
really will determine how much a protein
you really need to replenish
those amino acids
so less than two eggs a day is not going
to cut it okay so maybe if you have two
three
four or more eggs per meal now we're
getting to an amount that your body
really needs to satisfy its requirements
since we're on the topic of eggs if you
haven't seen
this video okay on chickens you might
want to check that out i put it right
here
you